the global lockdown and restrictions
have created a situation in which women
at risk of abuse may feel like they no
longer have a way out here's a look at
some of these statistics from around the
world now the French government had
offered to pay for hotel rooms for
domestic violence victims after reports
of abuse jumped by 36 percent since the
lockdown began two women have been
murdered India saw abuse cases double in
the first week of restrictions on
movement nationwide that's according to
the National Commission for women in
Australia internet searches for domestic
violence support networks rose by 75
percent the National domestic abuse
helpline in the UK has experienced a 25%
increase in calls and online requests
since the lockdown came in and to
newzeas women's affairs minister says
abuse cases have gone up at five times
the usual rate since a curfew was
imposed in March
well the giordano is director of
training at Men's stopping violence he
joins us on skype from Atlanta Georgia
thank you for your time so we are
talking now about violence primarily
against women while under lockdown how
do you do your job engage with men to
end violence against women during this
time well first thank you for having me
on this morning so our job has become a
little bit more complicated now that
we're all working virtually many of our
programs our intervention programs with
men who have used abusive behavior are
now transitioning and being conducted
virtually in online classes as well as
our general engagement effort so our
mission have been stopping violence is
to engage communities and men to take
action to end violence against women and
so basically we're now a virtual
engagement organization but I guess it's
going to be different difficult or
perhaps impossible isn't it to reach
those households that are under lockdown
that haven't engaged with anyone before
it's going to be difficult to reach
those people this is quite an unusual
time with a global pandemic absolutely
there's there's a combination of
amic's right now that are increasing
rates of domestic violence so we know
that stress levels have gone up people
are financially strained people are
losing their jobs people's normal lives
are being disrupted but we also know
that when isolation when when victims
are isolated they have less recourse and
so instances of violence go up we also
know that when there isn't a consequence
for an abusers use of violence then they
can abuse with impunity in there and I
think that is what is happening now the
abuse person isn't able to get out a
call for help because the abuser is
always there with them how do we include
the male perspective I mean when I saw
we were speaking to someone from men
stopping violence it sort of raised my
Albert eyebrows because I'm interested
in and how do you think we include the
male perspective and the male role when
talking about violence against women
without shifting the focus away from
women's voices from women's stories from
women's experiences who are primarily
the victims well we have to acknowledge
that if women are primarily the victim
then is likely that men are primarily
the perpetrators but most men are not
perpetrators of violence but most men
also are not taking responsibility for
helping to end or reduce the occurrences
of violence so our message to men is
even if you're not one who's engaged in
abusive or controlling behavior you have
a responsibility in your community to
take action to speak up to confront men
in your community who may be engaging in
those behaviors one of the things that
we're offering currently is resources
and help over the phone so that anyone
who is using abuse can call us and we
can help with with tools or options
anyone who knows someone who is using
abuse can call us when we can
then think about how they may intervene
or have a conversation with that men so
it's it's it is a issue that primarily
affects women but men have a huge role
that they could be playing if if they
were willing to step up and that's
really the goal of our organization is
helping men to do that thank you for
your time there leads Yordano director
of training at men stopping violence
thank you
Kavita Krishnan is an activist and
secretary of the all-india progressive
women's association she joins us on
skype from New Delhi thank you for your
time just asked what are you seeing in
India hundreds of women are reaching out
put that in perspective for us the
lockdown was announced without any
warning so India had warning of the
approaching kovat 19 crisis since
January 30th but the government did not
tell people that any lockdown might be
in the offing and they suddenly
announced this 21-day lockdown that has
left a lot of women's who suffer
domestic violence taken by surprise so
they have not been able to secure
themselves or to leave the homes so they
find themselves trapped with their
abuser in many cases and I think that
the number of cases must be much higher
than what the National Commission of
women is talking about because India
does not have any national hotline or
any state-level hotline for domestic
violence survivors so this is a very bad
situation on the and there's also other
things compounding the situation which
is in India in general even when there
is no lockdown the tendency for the
police and other you know government
authorities to take domestic violence
very lightly or to make excuses for it
or to ask the woman complainant to go
back to the house of the abuser and not
expect any help is extremely common and
now clearly it is more common I mean I
only can speak from anecdotal experience
because of my own organizations
experience in dealing with domestic
violence calls during the lockdown but I
can tell you that the pressures you know
it's like it's explosive it's a it's an
explosive situation because there are
tremendous tensions because of the
locked
so loss of work loss of survival
resources greater domestic burdens on
women who are dealing with this
household situation where there is less
food and it's more difficult to survive
and in that situation may you know
abusive men have tended to take it out
on women inside the household especially
husbands against wives and so this is an
extremely concerning situation yes what
are the options then for women in India
who need health very few options exist
as of now because in general India's see
it's it's like what Miss Curcio Cortez
says in the u.s. that the pandemic has
poured gasoline on our existing troubles
so India in general has very poor
domestic violence you know help so we do
have a law against domestic violence and
there are supposed to be respondents to
help women who are in trouble but we
have very we have no shelters so the
state-run shelters tend to be viewed as
jails by the women so their women are
not treated well there and so we
basically have very little public
spending on shelters in general or in
other other forms of help and in this
lockdown situation naturally the kind of
help and resources have gone down
because here even if you need an amp and
I say this from experience even if you
need an ambulance in a hurry for someone
who is suddenly ill you can't get it in
the city of Delhi which is India's
capital city all right now just imagine
how you know what women have gone
through when they have had trouble if
they call the police the police say what
is this we are in the middle of this
pandemic and you're complaining about a
quarrel with your husband don't bother
so recently a note recently some
feminists put out a little video
explainer in India about domestic uses
prior to the lockdown about how the
police tend to play down domestic
violence and make excuses for it and
this is again something which is all the
more excesses created during the
lockdown a lot of work to be done thank
you for your time Kavita Krishnan from
the All India progressive Women's
Association